So the last processor to arrive at the root
of the tree, in this case P5. He's the guy
who is going to start the waking up process for
everyone, and the way the wake up process works is
that P5, having realized that he has reached the
root of the tree and having realized that he's the
last one to arrive, because count is already zero
after you decremented it, he's going to flip this locksense flag.
So, when he flips this locksense flag, what's going to
happen? Two things, one is this guy, P3, he's
waiting on this locksense flipping. So he's going to be
released from the spin he's on. Of course, P5 has
reset the count back up to n to prepare
for the next barrier and it has flipped the locksense.
So freeing up P3 and it is now ready to go down the tree as well to tell his
buddies that the barrier is done and wake
up everyone along the way. So the wakeup starts
from the root. And, so in this case P5
and P3 having been released from the root, they
go, come down to the next level. And they're
going to wake up their buddies that are waiting at
this level of the tree. Remember I told you
that this can be a kauri tree. K happens
to be two in this case. But for any
general K, basically at every level of the tree, there's
going to be on K minus 1 buddies waiting here,
K minus 1 buddies waiting here. So what we're going to
do is we're going to release that many number of
prisoners from every level of the tree. So this is
the zeroth level of the tree. There's the first level
of the tree. There's the second level of the tree.
And at the zeroth level, there is k minus
1 buddies. At the first level, there is k times
k minus 1 buddies waiting. And similarly as you
go down the different levels of the tree, there're more
and more buddies waiting to be released. So for
this simple example, with the K equal to two, so
when he comes up here, comes down to this
level, P3 is going to release P0 and P5 is going to
release P6. And so now we have more helpers, to go down the tree and wake up
more people. So at this level only P5 was there to wake up P3, and at this level
both P3 and P, P5 are there to wake
up the respective buddies, P0 in this case, and
P6 in this case. So once P0 and P6 have been woken up, there are four of them
now available that can go down to the next level
of the tree. And they can go down to the next
level of the tree. P0 can wake up, his buddies
at this level of the tree, P3 his buddies at this
level, P5, and P6. And so now all the others,
so P1 in this case P2 in this case, P4 in
this case, and P7 in this case, were all been waiting
at this level of the tree, they will all get awakened
because of these guys marching down from the root. And
basically what each of these guys are doing on the
way down is to flip this locksense flag. So the
first thing that P5 did was to flip the locksense flag
over here. That released this guy. And when, when P3
and P5 come to this level of the tree, each
of them respectively flip the locksense flag that is associated
with this data structure and when they do that, P5 release
P6, P3 release P0 and now both P0, P3, P5 and P6 on this side.
They all can go down to the next level. And P0 can flip locksense over here, P3
can flip locksense over here, P5 over here,
P6 over here. That is going to release the
rest of the buddies, P1, P2, P4, and
P7. And everybody has now been released from the
barrier, and that signals that the spin is done for all the
ba, the processes that I've been
waiting, and, the barrier completion is complete.